our subject for today is the holy day we welcome
you again to the series of presentations entitled
the roots of truth and the purpose behind this
title the roots of truth it is our purpose to show
that the major doctrines of the bible
all originate from the very first three
chapters of genesis and to a greater degree
within the first 11. let me say that again
this series of presentations the roots of
truth is based on the observation it's a
biblical observation that the major doctrines
of salvation are rooted and originate within
the first 11 chapters of genesis particularly the
first three and when someone understands that that
person should begin the study of any subject as
far back in the bible as he or she can possibly go
to begin the study anywhere else is to expose
oneself to error and to false conclusions jesus
followed this pattern when he was explaining the
events of the passion week or the passion weekend
when the bible says beginning at moses and all
the prophets he expounded unto them in all the
scriptures the things concerning himself also
in matthew 19 when the pharisees came to him and
asked him a question is it lawful for a man to put
away his wife for every cause that's matthew 19 3.
the bible says in verse 4 and he answered
and said unto them have ye not read
that he which made them at the beginning made them
male and female and so jesus took his listeners
to the beginning as far back as he could go on
the subject his marriage and that was to the event
that he himself carried out when he put adam and
eve together and in verse eight after they brought
another objection to his answer as we tend to do
we never satisfied with what god says and what he
says is not what we want to hear jesus said moses
because of the hardness of your hearts suffered
you to put away your wives but from the beginning
christ repeats the principle it was not so and so
christ answers a question in the sinful world
by referring to the way things were before sin
let me repeat that it's an example for us when
we have to answer questions about the sabbath we
should begin at that time in history when there
was a sabbath but no sin if we have to answer
questions about sex we should go to the time
in the world when there was no sin but sex was
arranged by god if we answer questions about diet
we should go to the time when there was no sin
but there was a dietary recommendation if we have
to answer questions about the family we should go
to that time when there was no sin but there was
a family what i am saying is we should follow the
example of christ and as far as possible we should
go back to the beginning to answer any question
even questions on the judgment we should go back
to the earliest chapters of the book of genesis
questions on the philosophy of work in society
we should go back to uh the time when there was
no sin but there was work it is amazing how
many fundamental questions can be answered
by carefully studying the first three chapters of
the book of genesis and that's what we'll attempt
to do in this series to a limited degree because
six presentations surely cannot answer all the
questions that can arise our subject for today is
the holy day we will be dealing with the sabbath
and we will restrict ourselves primarily
to the first three chapters of the book of
genesis particularly the second and we
will establish the roots of that truth
once the root of a truth has been established
it serves as the guide for subsequent study of
that subject yes layers of truth may be added
but the direction of that study cannot shift
from the direction established by the root of
that truth because it is the root that counts
hence the title of the series the roots of truth
let's go to genesis chapter 2 we shall read from
verse 1 well bastard let's go to genesis 1 we
shall read from verse 1 of genesis 1 our subject
is the holy day the bible says in genesis 1 1 in
the beginning god created the heaven and the earth
using the principle of studying here a little
there little we go to verse 1 of chapter 2.
thus the heavens and the earth were finished
on all the hosts of them and on the seventh
day god ended his work which he had made now we
take the word work in verse two of chapter two
and we use it to help us to understand that
creation is work genesis 1 1 in the beginning god
created the heaven and the earth verse two says on
the seventh day he ended his work so that creation
is work by the way the very first person in the
bible to work is the creator and the very first
person in the bible to rest is the creator let
me say that again god set an example of hard work
and he set an example of refreshing rest we're
told in exodus 31 18 he rested and was refreshed
and so in the beginning god created the
heaven and the earth i think i said exodus 31
18 it should be 31-17 he rested and was
refreshed god created the heaven and the earth
he took six days to do that chapter two from
verse one tells us thus the heavens and the
earth were finished and all the host of them
this word all in connection with the sabbath
is mentioned three times in genesis 2 1 to
3. let's read that entire passage thus the
heavens and the earth were finished on all
the hosts of them and on the seventh day
god ended his work which he had made and he
rested on the seventh day from all his work
which he had made and god blessed the seventh day
and sanctified it because that in it he had rested
from all his work which god created and made now
what is the significance of this recurring theme
all his work all the hosts of them were finished
he rested from all his work the sabbath at the
physical level teaches us that god rested from all
the physical creation of the earth and the heavens
but all of creation is designed to teach spiritual
lessons in child guidance page 45 paragraph three
ella white writes the whole natural world is
designed to be an interpreter of the things
of god now the word design means something
done deliberately listen again to the words
child guidance page 45 paragraph three
the whole natural world without exception
is designed deliberately arranged by god
to be an interpreter of the things of god
the very same book child guidance page 46
paragraph three she writes in the natural world
god has placed in the hands of the children of men
the key to unlock the treasure house of his word
the unseen is illustrated by the scene
divine wisdom eternal truth infinite grace
are understood by the things that god has made
and so this tells us that in studying creation
we ought to look for spiritual lessons it's on
the basis of this principle that jesus stole
the parables the kingdom of heaven is like the
grain of mustard seed he goes from the natural
the physical creation to the spiritual application
this is by god's desire no wonder the devil has
gotten into us to pollute and destroy the physical
world because the more we pollute it the less we
see the lessons that god has there for us
that is why a faithful christian should be
an environmentalist i'm not a politician but we
should do all we can to preserve god's environment
because he placed into it lessons of his love
and so when we look at all all all thus the
heavens and the earth were finished and all the
hosts of them and on the seventh day god ended
his work which he had made and he rested on the
seventh day from all his work which he had made
and god blessed the seventh and sanctified
it because that in it he had rested from
all his work the spiritual lesson for us is that
the sabbath is a celebration of a finished work
there was nothing else god had to do
physically to provide a world for adam
and eve that had everything they needed for
the physical three-dimensional happiness
spiritually when christ died on the cross and
he said it is finished everything required
for salvation justification sanctification
everything associated with salvation had been
accomplished by christ and it was only when he had
done that that he died he said it is finished then
he gave up the ghost and rested in the tomb
that same christ before he took on human form
as the creator it is said of him thus the heavens
and the earth were finished and all the host of
them so lesson one which we learn about the
sabbath as we examine the roots of that truth
is that the sabbath is a celebration a reminder
a memorial that god has done everything necessary
for our comfort not simply physical that's not the
most important but spiritual for our joy for our
salvation for us to enter into a relationship with
him that makes us one with him not makes us god
but makes us in a mysterious way one with him all
necessary all things necessary for our salvation
the creator did he provided all things
necessary for our physical happiness
and through the cross everything necessary for our
spiritual happiness and they are connected and so
we have all all or every weekend when sabbath
keepers observe that day they should remember
now there is nothing else god needs to
do it is up to us to accept by faith
all that has been done for us
in the person of jesus christ
let's look at something else that's repeated
over and over in those first three verses we read
verses 2 and 3 of genesis chapter 2 as we continue
with the subject the holy day the bible says in
verse 2 of genesis 2 and on the seventh day god
ended his work which he had made and he rested
on the seventh day from all his work which he had
made and god blessed the seventh they unsanctified
it because that in it he had rested from all his
work which god created and made three times where
told the seventh day the seventh day the seventh
day all scripture is given by inspiration of god
second timothy chapter 3 verse 16 the spirit that
inspired the old testament writers to write the
books of the old testament was the spirit
of christ first peter chapter 1 verse 11.
and so christ is the one repeating to us
over and over the sabbath is the seventh day
it is the seventh day it is the seventh
day the very root of that truth has the
seventh day as the day of worship not the day
just of worship but the day of rest and worship
because we should worship god seven days a week
that's not the issue the issue is which day is
the sabbath the seventh and we're told that at
the very root of that doctrine the seventh day
the seventh day the seventh day now if you are a
person who has an interest in biblical numerology
what do the numbers mean bible scholars agree
that the number three is a divine number it
represents god father son holy spirit and so
three times if you want to view it that way
god tells us the seventh day because it's his
day the seventh day the seventh day and so when
people go to matthew 28 verse 1 and in the
end of the sabbath as it began to dawn toward
the first day of the week i actually heard a
preacher on the radio use that verse to say
see what the bible is saying the seventh day
has passed now we gone towards a new sabbath
the first day i heard someone say that and
i said to myself father i cannot understand
how people read the plain word of scripture
and come to such satanic conclusions
the seventh day is the sabbath of the lord thy
god this has been the way it was from creation
that is the way it has to be in isaiah 66 23
we read and it shall come to pass that from
one new moon to another and from one sabbath to
another shall all flesh come to worship before
me saith the lord as it was before sin so shall
it be in the dispensation when sin is no more
the seventh day and so we've seen that at the
root of the teaching of the sabbath we're taught
that the sabbath is a celebration a reminder
a memorial of a finished work everything god
had to do at the physical level was done
everything necessary for our spiritual
life for our rebirth and our continual growth
in christ has been presented or provided by
the same person who created physically and
that is jesus christ we've also learned that
at the root of the sabbath doctrine is the
seventh day the seventh day the seventh day
and we must continue in that vein if we are to
be faithful to the root of that teaching we go
back to verse two and three of genesis chapter
two and on the seventh day god ended his work
which he had made and he rested so we have ended
rested rested and ended as an equivalent to rested
because when you rest you're no longer working
when you end you're no longer working so
functionally ended rested rested or all the same
thing here again we have three times we're told
that the creator who was christ he was not called
christ back then but understand clearly the
creator is christ i was in a certain part of the
world preaching and i preached on christ's creator
in the seventh day after the church members
came to me to thank me because they did not
know christ was created let me say it again
they came to thank me they did not realize
that christ is the creator which means if
you do not understand that christ is created
you cannot understand christ as savior because
the two are inseparable but anyway christ he
rested ended rested rested three times we're
told that the savior having done a finished work
he ended it on a certain day he rested he rested
he rested so at the root of the sabbath is the
concept of finished work is the concept of
the seventh there is the concept of rest
at the root of this doctrine
let's look at something else
i've said in previous presentations i'll
say it again when you read the bible
read very carefully almost with a x-ray
vision if you will so that you miss nothing
and on the seventh day god ended his work which he
had made and he rested on the seventh there from
all his work which he had made and god blessed the
seventh day and sanctified it because that in it
he had rested from all his work which god created
and made three times we're told it's god's work
it is not by accident god made adam and eve
last and then did no more physical creation
after they were made when they opened
their eyes everything necessary for them
was provided they could not claim to have made
one blade of grass they were standing on the grass
one petal from one flower they were enjoying
its beauty everything necessary for our vibrant
ecosystem fit for human beings and animals
and plant life provided by whom by god now
the creator could have made adam on day one and
said adam help me to create you do that you create
grass i'll create trees you create
insects out create the huge animals no
adam did not exist until god had made everything
prior to adam that was necessary for a bountiful
world and so the bible correctly says it
was his work his work his work three times
here again we have that divine number and i
don't want to make too much of the divine number
but there's something to it three times his
work the root of the sabbath truth lets us know
that creation and salvation are the work
of god that's why the law can't save you
and coming from me that may sound strange
because i love to talk about the law but the
law cannot save you only the creator can save you
because he's the same one who functions as savior
his work of creation that's his work salvation
his work there's none other name under heaven
whereby we must be saved but by the name of the
creator that's jesus christ so it is his word
to create and salvation is a spiritual work
of creation when christ created the heavens
and the earth he created from nothing hebrews
chapter 11 verse 3 tells us through faith we
understand let me pause on that and
speak to you scientists the scientists
his or her method of understanding or
believing is to understand first then believe
that's a scientific method in other words i
must be able to measure it and measurement is
done by the eye the air the nose the taste the
touch it must be measurable or it doesn't exist
and anything measurable is something that
is comprehensible by the sensory apparatus
beyond that it doesn't exist as the scientist
goes the bible says in hebrews 11 3 through faith
we understand that's the precise reversal we come
to god by faith why because the very first chapter
as we said in the previous presentation gives us
the reason why you can trust his word and come by
faith because his word created all of that and god
said and god said and god said and so we come to
god by faith and because of faith god reveals and
reveals to us now the verse goes on to say through
faith we understand that the worlds were framed
by the word of god so that things which are seen
were not made of things which do appear this the
the bible scholars call that creation ex nihilo
out of nothing now i said creation and salvation
are related one is physical one is spiritual
salvation is spiritual creation
as god created out of nothing
at a physical level he saves the same way
he creates out of nothing let me explain
romans 7 18 paul says for i know that
in me that is in my flesh dwelleth what
no good thing nothing good in the flesh in other
words the flesh cannot come to god and say father
here is a little raw material start with this
and transform you can't do that there's nothing
we can offer galatians 5 17 paul says for the
flesh lusteth against the spirit and the spirit
against the flesh and these are contrary there
is no similarity between the flesh and the spirit
jesus said in john chapter 3 verse 6 that which is
born of the flesh is flesh that which is born of
the spirit is spirit there is nothing of the flesh
in the spirit nothing of the spirit in the flesh
jesus himself said in john 6 63 it is the spirit
that quickeneth the flesh profiteth nothing
that's why they that in the flesh cannot please
god the flesh profiteth nothing therefore for
god to do a work of transformation in our lives he
must do it out of nothing there's nothing we have
that's why salvation is spiritual creation it is
brought about by the word james 1 18 of his own
will begat he us with the word of truth first
peter 1 23 being born again not of corruptable
seed but of incorruptible by the word of god which
liveth and abideth forever and so it is his work
only god can save us christ his work his work
his work the sabbath is a constant reminder
that only the creator can save us the one who
created and by the very same power the very same
divine instrumentality the word that is how he
saves us the sabbath truth the root of it tells us
it's a constant reminder of the remarkable power
of the creator to save us but there's something
else associated with his work let's take a
look at it and on the seventh day god ended
his work which he had made and he rested on the
seventh day from all his work which he had made
and god blessed the seventh there and sanctified
it because that in it he is rested from all his
work which god created and made now we have an
interesting uh development here we have his work
which he had made his work which he had made his
work which god created and made now the the the
test could have said and on the seventh day god
ended his work without saying which he had made
but it would have been incomplete let me tell you
why it was necessary to have which he had made
what that expression tells us that his
work is a work only he could have done now
if you buy a toyota you can take it to a
mechanic who fixes that's not datsun's uh
hondas and you fix your car because all cars are
essentially built the same way are you with me
so a toyota mechanic can fix a honda if he's
any if he's worth the salt in his studies as a
mechanic but what god does no one else can do
are you with me someone built this auditorium
someone else could have built it someone made
this jacket someone else could have made it
any tailor can make this jacket beside the one who
made it but creation is his work which he had made
because no one else could do what christ did let
me be more inclusive no else can do what god does
so god's work is his work which he had made the
sabbath reminds us that what god does for us no
one else can do certainly not satan not a family
member not your boss not your career not social
connections god's work in your life and mine what
he does he alone can do and of course christ being
the creator christ being god the work of god in
our lives is a work that requires divine power
and the only source of divine power is god my
friends his work which he had made his work
it is amazing what we see when we
study carefully or we read closely
you and i serve a creator and i use the
word deliberately we serve a creator
service worship because the fundamental
purpose for worship is creation
the word worthy to receive glory and honor
and power for thou has created all things
and for thy pleasure they were and are created
revelation chapter 4 verse 11 the reason why we
worship christ god because he's the creator that's
the basis of worship and so the creator we worship
is that entity that power that being who does
for us what no one else can who forgives sins
the priest cannot do that we're at the spiritual
level now as creation let me say it again no
priest can forgive your sin because forgiveness is
a work which only god can do are you following me
no priest can move you from heaven to
hell if you pay a certain amount of money
because whether you go to heaven or
hell that's god honors our decisions
and casts believe in the hell he honors your
decision he admits us into heaven not a priest
the work of christ in our lives is a work that
only christ can do not christ plus somebody else
let me say that a friend of mine told me i'm a
smile when i speak because i look so mean and
although i'm angry and he's quite right but
sometimes when i present these messages i am
so eager for the listeners to get what i'm saying
do you understand that only christ can save you it
is his work which he alone can do and the sabbath
teaching the root of sabbath truth teaches us that
can you begin to understand why the devil has
attacked that commandment above all others and
so few people observe the seventh-day sabbath and
see the value of sabbath observance let's go on
look at look at that and listen to
genesis chapter 2 verses 2 and 3.
and on the seventh day now we
have ten words on the screen
three of them are nouns seven of them are pronouns
listen to them and on the seventh day god ended
his work which he had made and he rested on the
seventh there from all his work which he had made
and god blessed the seventh day and sanctified it
because in it he arrested from all his work which
god created and made ten times god is referred to
by noun or pronoun 10 in that small section those
two verses have maybe what 53 words or something
like that so that's one fifth of the contents of
that passage god god he his god god god no this
is the sound of truth this is the root what we
have at the root of sabbath truth is the sabbath
is all about god do you observe who's missing
mankind not mentioned at all not because god is
not thinking of them yes the sabbath will be given
to them but for the glory of god and whenever
we glorify god we benefit let me say that again
jesus said the sabbath was made for man and people
take that to me and they can do whatever they want
with god's day change it you know lacerate
it slice it up and no no no no the sabbath
was made for us for our benefit as we glorify
god in a special day special way uncluttered by
work when we do that we are blessed as we seek to
glorify god on his holy day and so genesis 2 2 3
highlights god does not mention man god he his god
his his he he he god this is a lesson in humility
what do i mean by that satan the problem he
had according to isaiah 14 13-14 for thou has
said in thine heart i will ascend into heaven
i will exalt my throne above the stars of god
i will sit also upon the mount of the congregation
in the sides of the north i will ascend above the
heights of the clouds i will be like the most high
that's pride but the sabbath properly understood
teaches us humility because where it is first
presented mankind is not even mentioned clearly
the root of sabbath truth is that god is the
center the focus the superstar of the sabbath
no wonder jesus says the son of man is lord of
the sabbath and we see that in genesis chapter
2 verses 2 and 3 because god he his god his his he
he he god all refer to christ particularly christ
now why do i say that in hebrews chapter 1 reading
from verse 8 the bible says this is god speaking
to christ very very fascinating passage in the
bible god hebrews 1 has god speaking about the
son and to the son but unto the son he saith thy
throne oh god is forever and ever a scepter of
righteousness is the scepter of thy kingdom verse
9 thou hast love righteousness and hated iniquity
therefore god even thy god hath anointed thee with
the oil of gladness above thy fellows now listen
to what god continues to say in verse 10 and thou
lord in the beginning the father calls christ lord
has laid the foundations of the earth and
the heavens are the works of thy hands now
if you don't believe what paul says about
christ is created in colossians 1 16 17
what john says in john 1 verse 3 and verse 10
what paul says in ephesians 3 9-10 surely you
can believe what god himself says from his very
lips thou lord in the beginning has laid the
foundation of the earth and the heavens are the
works of thy hands that's what the father said
you see the bible says christ
says i am lord of the sabbath
now i am not side sidelining the father in the
spirit don't get me wrong because the father
himself desires that we recognize the son as the
central figure of creation let's see how the bible
makes that so very clear as we keep that slide
on the screen listen to uh psalm 33 6 9 by the
word of the lord were the heavens made and all the
hosts of them by the breath of his mouth not their
mouths for he spake and it was done he commanded
and it stood fast the breath of his mouth
let's go to john chapter one reading from verse
one in the beginning was the word and the word
was with god and the word was god the same was in
the beginning with god all things were made by him
and without him was not anything made that
was made all things were made by him not them
now again i am not sidelining the father in the
spirit i'm just telling you what the bible says
as we try to understand genesis
2 2 3 where only god is mentioned
and that is the creator christ all things
were made by him and without him was not
anything made that was made for stan he was
in the world and the world was made by him
single singular colossians chapter 1 reading from
verse 16 for by him were all things created that
are in heaven and that are in earth visible and
invisible whether they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers all things were created
by him and he is before all things and by him
all things consist hebrews 1 verse 3 who
being the brightness of his glory and the
express image of his person and upholding all
things by the word of his power the bible is
super abundantly clear creation is the work
of christ now at the request of the father
don't misunderstand me the father did it through
christ the active agent was christ the voice that
said let there be light christ now having said
all of that he he he a singular reference to who
created heaven and earth now listen to genesis 2 2
3 again as we identify the nouns and the pronouns
and on the seventh day god ended his work which
he had made that's christ and he rested on the
seventh day from all his work which he had made
christ singular and god blessed us everyday and
sanctified it because in it he had rested from all
his work which god created and made jesus christ
was right when he said in mark 2 27-28 the son
of man is lord of the sabbath and it is right in
genesis chapter 2 verses 2 and 3 because he alone
is mentioned and those two verses mark 2 27-28
the sabbath was made for man not man for the
sabbath the son of man is lord of the sabbath
we see a reflection of that in the past passage
we just read the sabbath was made for adam and
eve and for all humanity not humanity for the
sabbath it was made for us that we may on that day
lift up the only person identified in verses
2 and 3 of genesis 2 and that is christ
the roots of sabbath truth by listening
friends tell us several things let us
well before we summarize let's
continue another slide on the screen
three things that the creator did here
again we have the number three divine number
and on the seventh day god ended his work which
he had made and he rested on the seventh day
from all his work which he had made and god
blessed the seventh day and sanctified it
numbers 23 verse 20 says what god
hath blessed you can't unbless
by the way what god curses no one can
uncurse let me say it again what god blesses
no one can remove what god curses no one
can lift that curse the bible identifies
three things the creator did he rested he
blessed he sanctified that's what he did
it is all the work of christ the creator
when you study the roots of the sabbath truth
we identify the day the sabbath before that
we identify that the sabbath celebrates a
finished world all the work that was
necessary was done so we have all all all
he rested he ended his work on the seventh
day the several day is identified three times
at the root of the sabbath teaching
here we have it three times
he rested he ended rested rested
the same thing three times his work
the work of creation is christ's work
the work of redemption is christ's work
he rested when his work was done but it's his
work which he had made in other words when you
see his work that's his activity follow me closely
when you read which he had made that's his ability
in other words god alone is able to do his
work and i hope you follow me his activity
and his unique ability his work his ability his
activity which he had made his unique ability no
one else can do it so the sabbath tells us that we
worship a creator who has powers no one else has
including the second most powerful force in the
universe and that is satan himself what else do
the roots of truth about the sabbath day tell us
it is all god like the presentation on the word
several dozen presentations can be made on the
sabbath so i'm just condensing giving you the bare
bone essentials from which subsequent studies
on the sabbath can be built and constructed
all emanating from this root of truth it is all
about the creator who is christ notice he his his
his he he he all singular and on the basis of the
seven singular pronouns we may reasonably conclude
that god god god also refers to that central
figure that's jesus christ and we saw in hebrews
1 the father is very happy to identify christ
as the creator of heaven and earth he blessed
he rested he's sanctified no human being can bless
no human being can sanctify what god has blessed
he alone can unbless if he sees fit what god has
sanctified he alone can unsanctify that is why
the commandment says remember the sabbath day
to keep it not to make it it has already been
made holy now keep it live in conformity with
god god has done on that day not make it holy
we're not called to bless the seventh day we're
not called to sanctify the seventh day we're
called to respect maintain guard guide defend
jealously what god did on that day he blessed it
he sanctified it and we're to keep it and the
word keep this just treasure it guard it when you
treasure something you protect it if a lady has
a mink coat she doesn't keep it in the basement
or in the laundry room cupboard she keeps it in a
special place in a in her room special mink coat
because she treasures it now sneakers as she runs
around in the gym she can throw that in the corner
in the garage she doesn't really treasure that
what we treasure we protect and so when the bible
says remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
treasure protect guard what god has made prepared
and presented to us the holy day our subject for
today as part of the series on the roots of truth
and we've taken a look today at the root
of the sabbath truth and for the final time
we shall go over what we've
observed about this day
it's a finished work the sabbath celebrates
all all all his work nothing left undone
so christ has you covered in every area of
your life he has you covered nothing is left
undone with regard to your salvation and your
physical and your spiritual happiness nothing left
undone we go to the next slide the several days
identified no matter what you study in acts romans
corinthians the day of worship is the seventh
day it is at the very root of that teaching it
was on the day that day that a creator ended his
work he rested he rested three times we're told
about the cessation of the creator's work on that
day all of that in the very root of that teaching
it's his work no one else can do it which he
had made he rested he blessed he sanctified
and of course in verses 2 and 3 it
is god god god he his he him indeed
genesis 2 verses 2 and 3 tell us that the god
the creator christ is indeed lord of the sabbath
my brothers and sisters having heard what you
heard i want you now to ask yourself the question
do i begin to understand why this commandment
above all others has been so successfully
attacked by the enemy because satan knows if he
can overthrow the sabbath commandment then he
effectively overthrows the force of all the
other nine because this is the commandment
that holds the first table and the sec it is the
hinge that connects the two it is the one that
identifies the person who issues the commands
none of the other nine does that not one of them
only the fourth when christ made mankind before
there was sin he instituted two holy things
the sabbath and marriage the bible says there'll
be no marriage in heaven but there'll be sabbath
observance ask yourself why of the two holy
institutions one ends with the coming of christ
one continues forever if that is the case
should you and i not take some time to study
the sub of doctrine and to ask ourselves the
question am i observing god's holy day am i
keeping the day holy so that i might receive the
blessings that are reserved only for that day
may god bless you my friends present and those
listening to the recording may god bless you
as you seek to honor his holy day a day that
lifts up and glorifies the creator himself
jesus christ who is not only
creator but savior god bless you
you